and we got um reream being completely
stupid this morning.
Reream is still being super weird
though.
They definitely had some sort of weird
outage.
Oh, well, you know, I'll just pull up
the um I'll pull up the YouTube chat.
And then I'll just get to work, I
suppose.
It's like incredibly obnoxious to me
when I'm just trying to start my work
and then my default service just like
randomly decides to not work and I have
to spend an extra 15 minutes fussing
with it.
There we are. It says live.
So, we'll see. Um, we'll see whether I
actually see stuff in chat or not.
Take this off. Okay, cool. So, what
we're going to do now today,
we have a whole whole day of work to do.
I want to get Puffer into a actually
like somewhat respectable state today.
Uh, and we're going to use Claude for
some of this, but the goal is to not
overuse it um today because, you know, a
lot of the mess we're cleaning up is
claw slot mess.
I also got the new puffer mug. Get the
puffer fish mug.
Hey, Liberty.
It looks like my chat is working
correctly. So, that's nice. At least
there. Now, at least I can see the chat
properly.
Stick something on the background and
then I'll I'll go through what we're
going to do.
Okay.
So, here's what we have to look at
today.
Yeah, I think I'm going to use Super
Maven a lot more than um Claw today.
We'll keep it lightweight.
Oh, this is a little sketchy, isn't it?
Well, wait.
Yeah,
we have to leave it the way it is. It's
annoying.
It's like so verbose.
Well, I think there are several things
we can do here.
Let's go get our um like our main
logging stuff done first.
Way too much. Yeah, don't do that, man.
That's bad.
But the thing is it's just wrong. Like
this is not It's like oh a single kernel
for copy plus cast [ __ ] A copy
is not a kernel.
All right. So, let's see what we want
this to look like because we have this
uh this sort of profiling shenanigans
going on here.
I kind of want to co-design this a
little bit with
What you doing today? We're going to try
to clean up everything a lot so we can
actually have this be like usable and
maybe have a pre-alpha.
this doesn't make sense, does it?
How does this make sense? What we're
doing here?
So pretty much like there's some tags
that have to be in here, right?
And if I can, I want to make it in a way
such that it's useful for um both the
main run code and the profiler.
[clears throat]
I hope I'm not getting sick. I feel a
little funky today.
Be super annoying. I literally do not go
anywhere other than here in the gym.
And yesterday I went to the gym, I ran
10 miles and I left
We'll go with kernels here. That should
be enough to test.
Tiny grad. Good or bad to support the
idea. So, I like a lot of what they've
tried to do. It kicks the hell out of
JS. Um, for sure. There's some stuff I
don't like. I really really wish that
their stuff were written in C or like C
with a Python bind instead of do it
being pure Python for sure. Um their
kernel gen is not fast enough and is too
abstracted right now so that it's
difficult to actually like get human
readable kernels and edit them and
stuff. But I think overall what they're
doing is fantastic. And I'm really a big
fan of like the software quality in a
lot of their stuff that they have is
just way way higher.
Um, unfortunately, Python is still
cancer. It's just like it's an
irredeemable programming language.
Lack a specific data structure for RL
mix of vector. Wait, lack a specific I
don't know what that means, dude.
database that will be a mixture. I don't
like that doesn't make sense.
cuz you don't want to go with M says,
right?
vibe coded a tiny grad clone.
Well, like you can't just say, "Oh, I
vibe coded a tiny grad clone." Like you
have like do you have numbers and stuff,
right?
because the number of people who have
told me, "Oh, I just five coded up a
thing and they've been wrong and like
it's actually been crap is very large."
So, I don't really necessarily care how
you did it. As if you have something
that you actually think is good though
and you have numbers to back it and
test, then I will look at it.
I'm just generally suspicious because I
have access to the same tools that you
do and I know that they're not as good
as people say they are and I know that
that type of a thing is outside of the
range of its capabilities to do well
All right.
Go on, link it then. I'll take a quick
look.
400 contributors
and tens of thousands. Well, I mean,
look, that's not all that's also not a
good signal, right? Cuz Torch has like
Torch is gigantic and Torch is garbage.
It's just the least bad thing that we
have.
But like Tiny, when I look at Tiny, I
can actually see like chunks of it were
made by like I can see chunks of the
design say, "Oh yeah, that was made by
somebody who knows what they're doing
and gives a fuck." Right? That's the
difference.
So like a lot of Tiny Grab, they just
need to fix Perf.
Like a lot of Tiny is Perf optimization.
It's kind of like a bad implementation
of a good design, which that's no show
that is no um that's no disrespect to
them, right? It's new. Of course, it's
going to be a bad implementation, but
the fact that they've gotten the design
good this early is pretty interesting.
Tiny Fin. Okay, let me look.
Let me look at this. I'll take a quick
look for you.
Okay. So, literally the very first thing
that you should have in here, Liberty,
um, is if you're going to have this, the
very first thing you should have is like
perk metrics, right?
This is a sim link.
Heck,
2,000 SPS.
You don't need CUDA for 2,000 SPS,
though. You can get way you can get
200,000 SPS on a CPU.
So like
what am I supposed to do, right?
And it looks like the element wise these
are being done on CPU as well.
Yeah.
I mean you've seen me like doing this
type of stuff on stream, right? like
you've literally been watching me using
to some extent quite heavily in places
um LLM tools but like you need so you
need obviously correctness tests I think
you have those um you need perf checks
you need some sense of how fast you
think that the op should actually run
right like look at this right
I have these
and I have timings versus torque for the
same offs right
I have cudograph timings
so I don't want to discourage you right
I do I want I actually what I'd like you
to do is like I'd like to encourage you
to learn more stuff with it right
you can keep using your same tools but
dig a bit deeper into it
you know write some higher stuff
hey Jess we're gonna We're fixing up a
lot of stuff in puffer today.
Okay, so this does not contain
that is weird.
Are those implemented in C or Python? So
my stuff I have
uh I have a variety of things, right? I
have kernels in CUDA. I have C++ torch
bindings. I have tests that are C uh C++
CUDA. The test could just as easily be
Python. Um I actually think it's not
really any easier to do it in Python, so
I just have them in um in C++ and CUDA.
Um
like I have several things. It's all in
40 if you look at some of the recent
stuff.
And for reference, just to prove to you
that this is completely doable, I did
not know this stuff, uh, I'm gonna say
six months ago,
I had not I had written one kernel ever
before I started Puffer 40,
but I'm putting the effort into like
actually understand this stuff. And I'm
not just outsourcing it all to Claude,
right?
You need to be a little bit more
disciplined, I would say, with how you
use the tools.
You definitely don't want to use it in
place of learning something.
You should use it in place of like
having to deal with a bunch of
boilerplate crap that doesn't actually
mean anything and mostly just waste your
time.
You'll get to see if you're watching
today, you'll see a lot of this stuff
that I'll be working on.
I have a ton a ton of stuff that I want
to get done with this today.
Interview at OpenAI. Congrats, man.
I have no idea how it is anymore, but
when I was there, when it was a much
smaller company, I've been very public
in saying it's the best place I've ever
worked.
I've been critical of a lot of the stuff
they do nowadays, but that much is still
true.
I think I just did this in the wrong
layer, right?
I think these can get queued parallel,
can't they?
push for real RL. Yeah,
honestly, just we don't need um I don't
need the backing of one of the bigger
companies to do this anymore. It's just
fine. Like everything's going to be
working in a year or two. Uh we don't
need additional investment to do it at
this point.
Okay, that's fine.
events are stream ordered
But then I can't do these NVTX tags,
right?
Um,
so the way that they're doing it looks
to be reasonable for now. uh we'll see
whether it remains reasonable going
forward.
As soon as companies start putting ads
into the uh into the actual LLM output
though or having the LLM itself
advertise stuff to you rather than just
putting it on the side like no burn it
with fire.
Oh, hey Sam. Seen the dev channel? I
have not.
I uh I had an important meeting
yesterday and then I crashed for a bunch
of hours.
What do we got?
I have been messing with your drone code
for something though. Oh, um Sam, can
you answer something real quick for me?
Uh there is no I can't get the uh the
current drone to render. Like
there's this um include render like the
render file doesn't seem to be included.
What am I looking at in dev? Oh, holy
[ __ ] Let's see.
Wait, why doesn't it play a stupid
Discord?
Hang on.
Discord. Damn it.
Give me my movie.
No, it's a dot move. Great. I can't play
it. [ __ ] Um,
hang on.
Don't you dare try to make me make an
account. Stupid f ofmpeg rapper.
I don't think you're live on X. If I'm
not live on X, it's cuz reream is
broken, man.
pushing out. Maybe you win 1 million.
What do you mean you win 1 million
then it crashed? Yeah. So, uh,
unfortunately everything is super jank
today. Like reream is a mess.
Do I not have literally any video? I
don't have a video viewer on this
machine.
All right, one second.
I love how with Linux I I love that
Linux that's how you get a video player
in 5 seconds.
Okay. Yo, [laughter]
is a drone?
Holy.
Wait,
this is the RL agent, right?
What am I looking at?
And also, I'll tweet real quick that I'm
live on YouTube on uh YouTube all day.
fully onboard model, direct motor
control, 100 lines of firmware.
This is sweet.
Taking off. And then we swap using the
RL controller.
Okay. Awesome.
That's sweet.
Lighting in the hallway hovered for five
plus sec. The lighting in the hallway.
Oh, what's the um Wait, what's it need
lighting for? Like what sensors does
this thing have? Oh, it probably has um
like a depth sensor or something.
Yeah. No, the OpenAI ads aren't bad,
Jackson. I'm not going to just blindly
hate on everything that they do.
If they keep it that way, it's fine.
It gets a bit wobbly as the RL
top article next two weeks. Yeah,
there's no way like a niche RL article
is going to do that upflow. Okay,
well that's freaking awesome.
Yo, Finn, does the um does the current
one work?
Does the current like drone uh ends work
in Puffer 4?
Because I remember I merged some PRs and
I started trying to use it for something
tested it. Well, no, it doesn't need to
train on 40, but like there were some
end changes.
It should be fine otherwise. Okay. So,
like cuz there were some end changes and
like I went to do this here. I think
this will still work.
So, I don't know. Is there like was this
a bad merge or something because it
doesn't have it doesn't have the render
bindings.
try an unstable training run. No, Jess,
it might be by the end of today if
you're lucky.
Yeah, if you could just figure that like
thing. Thanks. Um, that would help. Um,
I don't know. I just have an M I'm
working on that like is um uses a
minimalized version of this. And I was
confused if if I broke training or if
training was already broken or what.
Drone PR to four. Since you already have
it in four, you can leave it in four.
And go back to four. Yo.
All right. Thank you. Nice progress.
Very, very solid.
Yeah. this.
So,
Okay, so my NVTX regions aren't really
doing anything like this.
What would need to be done to fix
refactor autotune?
Oh, autotune is going to be so the
problem with autotune just it was meant
for like the old CPUs
like the whole VE is going to be
different. We may or may not even need
it in the new version. We'll see.
Yeah. Okay. So, we just don't need this
then. I think we just don't need this at
all.
Okay. So, this will be better for the
profiler.
Next PR should be three.
Is it No, I thought Didn't you already
PR the drone to puffer four or is it in
three? It should be to wherever you
already have the uh the drone.
I thought you did it to four.
Is this not the latest one here? This is
the one where you you guys merged
everything, right?
So that you have like a single drone
end.
Yeah,
it's in three. This is bor right here.
Four. Look right.
See, these functions are still such a
freaking mess.
423 into three. Okay, so we've mixed
them then, unfortunately.
Wait,
why are they both here?
Oh, it's in both. Okay, that's fine.
You can do it to three then, Sam. It's
fine.
Historical freezing for self player with
great success.
Oh, cool. Yeah, it looks like you guys
are making all good progress and I just
need to crank puffer four out for you.
I'm going to try to make this like not
utter crap today. Um, I have to make it
so that this profiling is less invasive.
[laughter]
The puffer mug was a a personal gift to
me for my birthday.
Need to finish off some coursework. More
progress. Awesome.
Yeah, cool stuff, Sam.
Trajectory track. Wait, what do you mean
trajectory tracking?
Let me know if you guys start breaking
the extra blades on the uh the drone and
need me to send you more so that we get
you your parts.
I think I got you a pretty small kit.
I think I got you some extras, but I
don't know if I got you enough.
From what I've heard from Drone Labs
people, it's expected that you break a
bunch of parts.
Okay, so yeah, the problem with these is
that these functions are now stupid
massive, right?
I I don't [ __ ] claw to do this,
right?
I need I should just know how to do
this.
Oh,
so there's you then,
Now, let's see what the um
let's see what our functions look like.
It's still a mess. Well, first of all,
it did really stupid spacing.
a kneeling rewards. Spencer suggests
passing an action.
Passing as an action. Wait, what?
No,
don't do that. You would literally
Okay, literally all you would do,
let me show you.
Okay, you see this this cosineing
function we use it for the learning
rate. You would just throw it on the
reward coefficient.
So you would just enneal cosign anneal
the um material reward to zero
over the course of training and you'd re
sweep.
Oh, I see what you mean. Just as a hack
to get the coefficient. Yeah, you can do
that if you want
it. You It's going to be a little
awkward though because you don't want
that bot to output it and you don't want
to mess up your um your buffer spaces.
He I think he was just coming up with a
quick hack to communicate it to the end.
That would make sense.
just passes dropped.
No, because they get repeated.
This is the main chunk of the code that
I want to be like less bad.
All right, I got to use the restroom. I
got to make myself um my morning protein
shake. I'm going to be a few minutes and
then uh we're going to be deving the
rest of the day. Okay, and it's going to
be a little bit weird today because this
is basically the how do we clean this up
so it's not such a mess day. And there
are a few pieces of this that are like
actually requiring some thought and then
most of it's going to just be little
bits of fiddling here and there. We'll
see.
Um, there's also going to be I'd like to
get more uh multiple end of bindings
working and stuff like that. So, we got
a whole bunch of time today. I'll be
right back.
I'm going to be ridiculous today cuz I'm
feeling kind of sick and I'm going to
keep myself warm.
Also, literally everything in my body
hurts. Literally everything in my body
hurts from all the training.
So, I'm going to be ridiculous in a
bathrobe on stream today. Too bad.
Yeah, I don't know. Just I feel a little
bit off.
So, I had an idea though in the process
of doing this. Um,
I had I think a decent idea.
So,
the signatures are just getting way too
long, right?
No, I didn't lift too heavy. Sore is not
bad.
I'm not hurt.
It's a So, I'm super sore from hard
training this week. And then I think I
also like I got exposed to some pathogen
I'm fighting off.
Here's what I'm thinking though, guys.
Um,
I think that these signatures to the
functions, we can actually keep it
functional
or whatever. We don't have to pass
paparl like this god object. We don't
have to pass this. Uh but what we can do
is we can pass like we can make
this for instance
a uh an arg
like this.
Yeah. I'll show you what I mean here.
Claude will do it.
This is literally like I think Intelligj
would already do this, but
Puffer. Uh, go. There's one other
exploration thing, Jess, but just that
like I Puffer 4 is taking so long. I
want Puffer 5 to be a more directed
algorithmic update.
so I guess just one good way of putting
it would be
If you can get something that looks more
like exploration is proportional to
um the minimum of the if you get
exploration like there's this
exponential factor in terms of the
number of random actions it takes to get
a reward. But then there's this other
factor which is the number of states
that there are to cover.
and you should be able to get
exploration proportional to the minimum
of those two rather than to just the
exponential like random action one. So
there's there's essentially there's this
very quantifiable thing that has nothing
to do with this like highle lofty view
of exploration
um that's very easy to test directly and
that I expect to have strong transfer to
many ends.
This is nice in the sense that this
doesn't really change the code one bit,
but it does clean up all the sigs.
I'm gonna have to see after this
what it looks like.
I guess whether this is good or not is
going to depend on um
yeah, this is going to actually quite
well depend on
what function functions need access to
what buffers
Okay. So, it didn't update any of the
Thanks.
I'm trying to think why I'm doing this
and why this feels good today.
Honestly, I think it's because of the
cudigraphing, right?
I think I just don't like the Well, it's
the cudigraphing and the testing.
I don't like the idea of having to
recreate puffer roll for testing
with the ends and Everything.
See, I don't like this is getting
longer, this call, but I think it's
going to like I think this will get
shorter.
final.
Okay. So now what we'll do is
Yeah, ultimately the reason for this is
profiling, right?
I think that's because what I would
normally do is I just not have this be a
function and I would just inline this
code, right? Like why split out a
function when you can just inline the
code?
But in this case, it's so we can profile
it
separately outside of this
Okay, we're going to see what this looks
like afterwards and if this is actually
easier to read.
the entire point of doing this, let me
let me uh kind of explain. So the reason
that things are like this, right?
Normally if I were just writing this, I
would write the code top to bottom and I
would not break out separate functions
for things that are only called once,
right? like why have a separate function
where you have to deal with all the jank
of this signature when I can just put a
comment that says train like copy train
graph stuff or no comment if it's
obvious. Um but the thing is because I
need to profile blocks of code like this
and I need to be able to profile them
not just during training they do need to
be split out into functions which means
that you do end up with signature jank.
All this would be the signature
otherwise which means I need to start
grouping things to make the signatures
less gross.
That's why it's a pain.
And then the goal is ultimately, you
know, we end up with something that is
no less readable than the original code,
no slower than the original code, but is
also uh able to be profiled relatively
easily
because otherwise you end up with 2,000
lines of train code and 2,000 lines of
profile code.
I don't like like adding, you know,
values.device now rollouts.values.de
device. I don't like this. So, we'll see
about this. Um,
this is going to be an iterative
process.
We're going to have to iterate on this a
few times.
We are losing code here which is a good
thing
in the process of doing this.
Hey user
This would actually be amazing if this
were just like 10 seconds instead of 3
minutes.
It's still very useful, but just less.
So,
I kind of have to keep myself active
thinking about
Yeah, some of these things are like
weird.
Uh how would you do that?
It's time dependent man right?
Calculating it once.
Wait calculating it once
isn't it per sample and time dependent
dude how could you premputee it?
Hey Rookie
electron optimizing writing good code
fire for no what do you mean it's not
wait this is so this is one row right
and then this is importance of t
the importance tensor is the same size
as values or rewards Right.
And then you need to do a min
ratio is always one.
What ratio is always one? Oh, but the
ratio shouldn't always be one.
The ratio is not one after the first
call initialized. Yes. So it's one on
the first call. But then when you
recomputee it, right, the whole point of
doing this is that importance isn't
always one. The entire point of doing
this is that when you do the second
update, so you do your second optim
step, it shouldn't be one anymore.
It's vtrace style importance. Uh it's
Vrace style.
Um clipped importance.
Okay, same speed
still works.
17. Okay, we're minus 100 lines of crap.
Uh, this should help
just like get rid of these absolutely
gross function sigs.
I'm going to try something after this
which is going to be I'm going to just
try to like stick comments in various
sections and then tell it to go through
and uh apply the changes
because this like back and forth term
interface This is so bad.
I want it in the editor, so I think I
can get pretty close.
Well, the thing is I hate like I hate
that it's taking you out of the editor.
Like, oh, you shouldn't be in your
editor editing code, right?
The whole interface of it is just very
antihuman.
Like, the model's good. The people who
made it are kind of [ __ ]
Yeah, honestly that wouldn't even be
that hard. Yes.
I see. I have the graphable functions
intentionally like this, don't I?
You know, I have the graphable functions
like this by design. It's quite bad.
Yeah. This is nice though because this
puts me back thinking about stuff.
How do I want to do this? You see the
problem, right? The problem is that we
have to graph a bunch of different
functions with different signatures. So,
I just made them all take puffer because
that's easy to graph.
That's irritating.
It's very irritating.
Okay, I think actually well we've
identified the main thing that's making
this difficult to clean up. Okay, maybe
if I just talk through this out loud,
I'll get some better ideas.
So,
here's the issue, right?
In Puffer 3.0, I just wrote the code top
to bottom as simple as possible, not
breaking out functions only used once.
Uh, this is really nice because it's
succinct. It's easy to read. There's no
additional structure to learn.
It's like pretty close to clean RL. It's
actually really, really solid. And um
it's good for like larger pieces of code
than most people would say would say.
Now the issue is
well there are two things we're
profiling stuff and we're cudigraphing
stuff right so
uh they both cause sort of the same
problem though cudigraphing it it makes
it a little harder. So first of all all
those chunks of code um like all the
different chunks of code need to be that
need to be profiled need to be split out
into functions. So we can do that.
Now for the most part these chunks of
code that we're profiling are also being
cudigraphed
which means that we need to uh we need
to call them at startup time
and they need to be called with the
right set of arguments.
Now I have this function for
cudggraphing
right? I do have this function for
cudigraphing but the way I did it.
capture? Yeah, capture graph. So you see
how this function works here. And this
checklist is because if you screw up
this function, you're not going to have
a fun day.
I can punt on it very easily in the
meantime.
Why are you not using a bitwise
operator? Where? What?
What? Huh?
What are you What are you talking about?
Let's go up to where we're going to
capture the graphs.
To make sure the right signature
Dude,
you make statements like that just they
do like this doesn't mean anything. Like
I can't even find I can't think of any
reasonable interpretation of your
statement
like a bitwise operator to make sure the
right signature is called
like what
Let me go look and make sure I didn't
mess anything up with these though.
I think this will be good.
So, the point here, I still don't know
how to fix this, but I think that this
will at least let us see if it's worth
fixing. Um,
because we'll basically at least get to
see what the test version would look
like.
That's good. What we want.
That actually cleans it up a lot.
This takes
That's a much more reasonable sig
though, right?
The lines aren't everything, but it's um
I take it as a good indicator that the
code is getting shorter as I'm doing
this, not longer.
I just clicked.
Mhm.
You better not be slower. There we go.
10 mil.
All right. Same thing.
It should be. I've just moved some stuff
around.
Let's take a look at what these clothes
look like now.
something like this though is fine,
right?
and all these hypers well will get
moved.
Yeah. So, it just did this weird thing
here.
Now it's directly here.
Yep. This is what we want.
Moved all the hypers into their own
section.
just from like merging signatures and
redundant things.
This goes away and then yes, good.
We're fine.
It's fine.
I think some of those are going to end
up having to get moved back, but mostly
it's good.
>> Okay, this is like a ridiculous number
of tokens on basic refactor.
Come on.
Well, that's annoying.
Yeah, cuz we have to do this hypers.
I don't even know if these things need
to be exposed, though.
And we might just not end up exposing
all this crap.
Main thing I want to look at is the
function seg.
Okay, it's fast. Cool.
Now, the main issue
the main issue that we're going to have
here
Wait, do these have to get tested from
um Oh, wait. No, we're totally fine cuz
these only have to get tested from the
torch API.
So, yeah, we're totally on the right
path.
Let's finish. Let's finish getting all
of these um these signatures to be
reasonable and then we'll see what we
have left.
Ah, I see
this is okay.
It's pretty simple.
Now, what do we think about this
section?
And then we'll make my other edits here.
Fold some stuff back in.
It's starting to get cleaner. It's just
going to take a lot of work.
There are like too many sources of just
mess.
No, you don't need to update the cud
thing, dummy.
But then this keeps roll out. advantage.
So this is still fine.
Okay,
let's go mark some stuff for um
let's go mark some redundant functions.
Too many of these little stupid
functions.
So miss, we're refactoring stuff
massively today.
Okay, after this one, we should be able
to actually see something and assess
whether we have um
we have something reasonably clean.
Nowhere near done, of course. Nowhere
near done. Better than nothing though.
Okay, I think we're happy with this.
Nothing broke.
Oh, this is so funny. I literally I was
thinking of this exact thing.
Wait, what? Oh, this is not the
direction I had.
Okay. His mind is not in a good spot
right now.
Yeah, his mind is not in a good spot
Spends too much time on X.
I will say though for hots, I don't
think he's making it up for clout or
anything. He's um from what I can tell a
pretty genuine guy. I think he's just
spent too much time reading his Twitter,
which is currently a total cesspool.
Let's see what our roll out function
looks like. Now,
as a university student, you should
learn what interests you.
Yeah, they all went to blue sky or
whatever.
It's mostly all this hyperprofile stuff
that's in the way of me reading the damn
code, right?
I mean, this has been easier, right?
Got a screen of code for rollouts.
This can also just be an int. It doesn't
need to be an N64T.
There's this thing here that's a little
annoying, right?
Okay, I think the next thing is to
figure out the graphing signature
cuz this is not bad already. Like we've
already cleaned. This is like way better
than when we started today already.
There's still so much left to do, but
way better than we started at least.
It's pretty similar to the old profiling
system as well.
I could probably do uh I could probably
add like a profile switch or something
to make it slightly lower overhead.
We will see.
I'm quite good though.
All right, let me figure that signature
thing out and um let me go grab myself a
nice mug of tea or something.
Freaking
shoulders acting up as well.
Keep it warm maybe.
If I look up
graph roll out.
Okay, this just gives you roll out copy
call, right?
Graph roll out copy call.
I don't think it's going to come up with
much. I don't I don't think there is a
good way around this unless there's some
disgusting C++ variable arg shenanigans.
Do you start over? What do you mean?
Do you start over?
buffer is way too big to do that at this
point, man. I scrap substantial sections
and start over. Or like in this case,
right, this update, all the C++ is new.
There was no C++. It's a port that's
brand new.
Generally, they're pretty heavy changes,
but I like you can't just start over.
Puffer's too big.
And it's not like too big in the sense
it's too much code, but there are too
many subtle things that you really need
to get right or everything breaks.
temple at the capture function. No,
we're not [ __ ] doing that. Screw you.
Look,
I'm feeling a little sick.
I'm super freaking sore today.
I'm wearing a damn bathrobe on stream. I
feel like it. All right,
so deal with it.
I don't like this, but this will take
out this indirection annoyance.
Um, well, first of all, you can make a
basic website with just HTML.
And then you can you'll probably want
some very light CSS
and some light JS. and you can get
pretty far. So, pretty much the fastest
way is to not try to do all of those,
like to learn all three and then make a
website, but to rather write the
simplest, dumbest HTML site you want and
then learn the minimal thing you need as
you're building a pro like real
projects.
Yeah. So, this is what I figured. So,
this is going to have
this has the capture calls in here,
right?
I know I can just make I'm making
website with AI in it. Where do I learn
ML?
Well, that's a much longer thing, right?
What the heck does a website with AI in
it even mean?
There's very little AI deployed on
websites. Actually, we have one of the
cleanest examples of that if you check
our um puffer.ai. We have all of our
agents for the games directly on the
website, but that's that's not
JavaScript really. like, yeah, okay, it
gets exported with some JavaScript glue,
but for the most part, it's just C that
gets compiled to web assembly.
So, I mean, the first thing you're going
to want to do is figure out like whether
you're asking the right questions.
Then that's just an API hook
that's not learning AI. like
what you're actually asking is how do I
set up a super basic website where I
hook in uh the API for some whatever
language model.
Okay, that's actually pretty nice that
we don't have to sort that. So this will
be slightly more code here but it'll be
more explicit and we will remove
uh we'll remove a few redundant
functions.
How would you do it? I have no clue.
I mean, the biggest mistake I made was
not doing lower level earlier.
Honestly, GPU dev I've just been picking
up in the last um last few months
just like learning how to write
basic stuff fast in C.
uh it really sets you up very nicely
because the thing is it just puts you so
much closer to the hardware that you
understand how everything is
implemented.
It just gives you a very different
perspective on programming
Okay. So, let's see how this looks,
right?
So, we have slightly more code here,
but we actually have
we have the call signatures now, right?
Which is nice.
Get the graph policy.
I bet you these RNG seeds aren't going
to be needed.
Start with books or ducks, right?
No, I don't. No book. Um,
I'd written like one kernel. Look, it's
pretty much like this.
So this was the one kernel that I wrote,
right? So I basically I wrote this
saying, oh this is literally just C,
right? Like this chunk of the code, this
just would compile and run in C. In
fact, everything except this host device
tag, right? This just runs in C. So this
is super basic kernel. And from here, I
had to figure out how to set up a basic
launch. So this was docs, right? You
know, just have to um invoke a launch.
And then there was some setup for this
required, but this was pretty simple.
And then I said, "Oh, okay. Well, you
know, basic kernel dev is really not any
different from writing C." And then of
course there's some like there's some
extra stuff that you have to think about
because GPUs don't work the same as CPUs
when you do things that are more
advanced. But, you know, it like this
gives you a pretty smooth way to start.
Like if you know low-level dev, it's
like it's not really a hurdle is what
I'm saying in order to start on stuff
like this, right? Like where's where's
the nut next kernel? Like mining grew.
Like here's the gate kernel. This is
also an elementwise kernel. And I wrote
like a couple smaller little kernels for
this.
I hadn't done templated stuff. I hate
templates, but I had I had to apply like
one templated thing here for a couple
type supports.
Um, and then there are a few more
sophisticated ones, right? So, it's all
incremental,
but like the point is this is not me
learning all of GPU dev, right? These
are very basic kernels, but the point is
I'm already doing some pretty ridiculous
things with just like these very basics.
Hey Tim,
we're currently refactoring puffer lips.
uh the C++
so that it's actually reasonably usable
and we can get ourselves towards a sort
of a pre-alpha type release. Is there a
way to test them right away?
Uh yes, you just have to you have to set
up NBCC.
So as long as you have your compiler
then yes.
But like the point is it's the point
country is like if you just start with a
very minimal version of whatever it is
you want to learn it's actually quite
straightforward to learn by doing in
docs and stuff um you know big formal
courses and books I find sometimes
helpful for filling in gaps but less
helpful for learning because it doesn't
get you working on something end to end
right away and often courses are
structured to like let you fill in
little chunks here and there where what
you really want to be doing is building
end to end things on your own as quickly
as possible.
Okay, we now have one screen of code for
our rollouts. Congrats on 10 mil. Thank
you.
A one screen of code for rollouts is not
bad, right?
Like this is getting towards something.
I could see us shipping. Not quite
right, but pretty close.
Is this not graphed?
Doesn't look like it.
see why your profile I'm so happy.
Yeah, exactly. Well, it's actually it's
kind of the other way around where I
have to refactor it this way.
It's not just because the profiling to
be fair. It's also because of CUDA
graphing. Even without this profiling,
I'd have to do it this way because of
cudigraphs.
So, I may as well get a two for one.
Let's get some more reasonable types in
here. We don't need freaking doubles on
everything.
only thing that's going to go above will
be uh steps can go into billions, right?
Yeah, I don't see anything there that
needs to be. Um,
Why does this one have
I literally just checked that
Oh, look at that. You see it takes
doubles here
and then it converts them to floats.
Anyways,
so we may as well just use floats.
C++ using doubles for everything by
default is just so gross to me.
Like the style just being double for
everything is blur.
Okay.
See if this runs.
Um, no. I've been using Opus. It's fine.
Like, it's just that the way that people
wanted me to use it was completely
stupid.
Like, the model is fine and I use it. I
use it probably for like way lighter
stuff
than people were expecting.
Honestly, the biggest feature sell for
me right now um would just be speed.
Like make the model faster.
Cheaper would be nice, but faster
definitely
is an assert. Yeah, I but I don't know
why they like this.
What is my Where's my freaking error
message? Huh?
This doesn't need to be. Where the heck
is it?
How? But same thing.
Okay, I'm just not seeing [ __ ] now.
The sad thing is I actually think Claude
would have fixed this by now. And um my
solution around this is not writing this
type of [ __ ] Like look at this. How
on earth could have anybody have thought
this is like
just putting the signature in a string
like this in a macro
so bad
Oh, I I know where it is.
It's this right.
I got it.
Uh yeah, Cloud would have actually
gotten that before me.
I mean, you see the stuff it is though.
It's like it shouldn't be built that way
in the first place. I didn't expect to
have to do that because it shouldn't be
this way in the first place.
Absolute garbage library, man.
Use float in the string, but then double
in the signature because float means
double.
[ __ ] off, meta engineers.
Why did you do this?
>> Okay,
there we go.
Okay,
let's see what we have now. We should
have something that's at least readable.
We've got a reasonably small puffer
strruct.
Just make everything more explicit where
tensors are involved.
I think we'll end up with output arcs as
well so we don't have to have these
freaking vectors everywhere.
Yeah, cuz I don't like that this is um
in a vector like this.
But I mean it's today it's been mostly a
few things that needed some more
subtlety to them, but mostly a series of
very simple
um precise transformations to the
codebase, right?
Some stuff cleaning up types. A lot of
stuff cleaning up function signatures.
some stuff like grouping data into some
STS.
Boom. Now everything is nicely typed as
tensors.
We got rid of most of the crappy auto
usage.
I really just do not enjoy any sort of
C++isms.
This to be way way similar to um our end
code.
That's nice.
Still works.
See what our roll out function looks
like now.
Oh, this is a graphing code. This is
still a mess. That's fine.
It's expected.
make sure this still works and then
we'll start on um
I mean there's several other things we
need to do.
Okay, this works.
So the next thing
It is infinitely better.
Dude, their jit sucks ass. I tried it. I
tried it quite extensively before I did
this. Jax is just an abomination.
It makes you write awful awful code
because some Google bro wanted to
abstract kernels and abstract tensor ops
out into Python.
No, it's not. I've tried it. It produces
slow [ __ ] code, too.
I have no idea what you're talking
about.
I benchmarked it quite extensively
versus Torch as well before I started
all this. It doesn't magically give you
this level of perf.
People like it because they don't want
to think about low-level depth, but it
doesn't for you from thinking about
low-level dev. It just lies to you and
says that you don't have to think about
low-level death.
It does speed up. No, it doesn't. I
tried it.
It's out of the box. No, it doesn't. I
I tried all of that. I have several
tests for it. It didn't [ __ ] work.
Torch compile also doesn't work.
But then what happens is that um
half the time the jet produces the same
speed as torch eager mode.
Well, the thing with Jax is you're not
intended to write any kernels. It's all
Python. So when you try to go lower
level, it goes d. You're not supposed to
do that.
We want you to jit everything. Yay. And
it's just no.
If I wanted a pure Python learning
library, I would use um Tiny, which at
least design-wise is infinitely better
than Jax and speed-wise is catching up
quickly.
Well, that's not the intended use of it.
No, the intended use of it is for you to
not understand what the [ __ ] is going on
under the hood, for you to type your
shitty Python and go [ __ ] off, which is
not what we do here, man.
You need palace. Oh yeah, you need
palace at slow level. I can write CUDA.
Maybe I can just not deal with Google's
[ __ ] Um, and I can just write CUDA.
At least when I deal with Nvidia's code,
it's actually good.
I don't like being tied to the hardware.
Um,
but at least their code is actually
good.
Their compiler is a black box. Yeah. And
I like it when it's not. But Google's
The thing is Google's is awful.
Like absolutely awful. Unusable.
I mean, Jax is just like your typical
Google bro. Oh, we're so clever. This is
how you should write software. And then
they produce dog [ __ ]
Like at the very least I would say that
Torch is Torch is a not particularly
competent uh implementation of a
dramatically better design.
Not all Google software is it I've yet
to see good software. I'm sure they have
some good engineers. Um but like most of
their stuff is just awful awful.
Honestly, I'm pretty sure at this point
the only like the only one of the big
tech companies that seems to write
generally good stuff is just Nvidia.
Like pretty much all of their tools that
I've had to interact with have actually
been Good.
Insight is undocumented.
I've been using Insight and it's been
great.
food is not undocumented. Are you
kidding me?
Okay, this is not bad.
Great roll outs. Was
matrix mold kernels.
That's like the one kernel that actually
has to be freaking stupid fast cuz
everything calls it
I don't think that they do everything to
blind you. Like the thing is
the API is sufficiently low level that
there's really not that much magic.
If this were like if CUDA were written
by um by Meta or Google, there would be
like you know some like memory copy
manager view thing that you use to move
data. I mean they just here's here's
your mem copy, here's your mem copy
async, right? Uh here's your stream. You
can like it's very nice and lowlevel
such that there's really not that much
guesswork.
Like if this were written by a different
company, they would give you a
fundamentally higher level API that
would just be big and bloated and a
mess.
What happened to big tech? You just
weren't paying attention.
See, PyTorch was actually very good when
it was introduced
um because the alternative was
TensorFlow or Cafe,
but then it kind of just kept getting
more bloated and then the uh the design
of Compile is awful.
people from big tent went to open AI.
Well, open AI was good when it was
smaller. I don't know how their talent
density is now.
Like none of this is recent.
The thing is it was always [ __ ] It's
not even in shitification. It just was
always [ __ ]
As soon as stuff gets big, it gets to be
[ __ ] Like not everyone at Nvidia is
good either, right?
Like it's their core their core low
level though.
And Cuda is good.
You think X AI?
No.
I think where we want to do where we
want to go from here with this.
Yeah. Like this this type of basic
thing, right?
Why C++?
I don't know. It's a terrible language.
To be fair, that's not why it's a
terrible language. Like, that's way far
down the list. C doesn't have keyword
args either. And like,
it's good. Whatever
Why the hell is the static cast?
Not do
I mean the thing is it's not even about
recreating the software stack. It's just
most of the time you don't need a damn
stack. You need like two things and they
grab 10,
Not break anything.
10 mil. Good.
Yeah.
Not breaking anything. Good.
actually I can give it something big
now.
I think I should do a little bit more on
this before I try to get it to update
the uh profile. Let's at least fix some
names and [ __ ] right?
I'm going to get another mug of tea cuz
like the goal of doing this all was that
we also were able to have profiling be
clean. So I'll be right back and we'll
do that. Also variable M. Lots of stuff
left. I'll be back.
I do think we're getting relatively
close here.
>> I mostly just want to rename a few
things and move some stuff around.
Get rid of this crap. We don't need
this.
Let's just think about some names real
quick.
That's going to be the main thing so we
can do the other refactor, right?
I hate these prototypes or these these
declarations are so bad.
Yeah. Everything's like super
inconsistent and crappy, right?
H naming things needs to be easier.
So
then we also have this mini batch T.
I do this mini batch T.
Let me look at all these. I think this
is the complicated one
cuz with the other one if I ignore
training,
if I just ignore um training
I could put everything in the graph
buffer to be fair, right? Let me think
about that.
Yeah. The thing that's giving me pause
here is that I'm having difficulty even
remembering what the hell everything is
in much my own library. That means it's
probably quite bad.
Wait, isn't this mini batch T just
redundant to suck?
That's what was confusing me is we had a
redundant str. So I was trying to keep
things straight because they were
actually the same.
Oh, that's really cool.
If that's actually real, that's pretty
cool that they have that good of a
modding API.
Yeah, that's like such a big win for
gaming in general. It's really cool to
see that this exists.
I don't know. I like games for AI, but I
also like games. It's nice to see
something like that once in a while.
Java. Yeah, I know. That's how I learned
to program.
you still play indies? I was. And uh
then I redownloaded old school
Runescape, so I've been playing that.
That's just my favorite game of all
time.
There are two games, only two games that
I've sunk like an utterly stupid number
of hours into. One is Old School RS and
the other is Dophus.
I don't know. I've always just been all
I've always really really liked the idea
of MMOs.
Absolutely love the work on Neural MMO.
Thank you. I mean, have you seen Neural
MMO 3? If you're coming from my thesis,
so we have right here on Puffer AI. This
is the follow-up environment to my
thesis.
Um, it is about a thousand times faster.
It's more complex. And we have actually
trained this thing on, I believe, 12 to
13,000 years worth of gameplay on one
server.
And this is now our probably our hardest
benchmark that we use for all the stuff
I build nowadays. I'm still doing neural
MMO things. Uh, and I'll probably end up
having to make a fourth one when we
eventually solve this. But this is only
a third of the way solved right now.
All multi- aents using the same
algorith. Yep. It turns out that most of
the algo work in um multi-agent just
doesn't work and you are kind of better
off just running PO normally.
Okay, so this is way better. So we have
an end buffer and a rollout buffer. And
then the only question is going to be
around
this stuff here, right?
So, I guess I just want to go see what
these three things are before I decide
what to do.
Rain forward call.
Oops.
What is counterfactual regret
minimization? No idea.
Okay. So,
right.
New value.copy.
I think for now it has to work this way
at least until we improve the algorithm.
So, there are a couple of these extra
buffers that are quite inefficient that
don't like fit anywhere cleanly.
Can I stick this in roll outs or not?
Really?
You'll see that the math only works
under very stupid conditions.
or with very stupid bounds.
graph train ratio graph train new How
are you?
So, this is actually MB ratio and this
is MB new value.
You say this is MB ratio. This is MB new
value.
Yeah, that's why I'm confused.
MB ratio.
reinforcement learning for science.
Oh yeah,
that's where we're going eventually with
this. Not even eventually, within the
next couple of years, Liberty.
I mean, imagine that we have a thousand
times better RL than we had literally
two, three years ago. Two years ago,
even
So
uh we have some options here. I can name
this mini batch.
So, I could name this this could be mini
bath.
Man, Ethan, that's completely
irrelevant.
And you're focusing on some of the wrong
problems.
I kind of like having this just be the
um the batch, right?
It's not strictly doing what the what
the value function doesn't even
influence the policy of a val time. What
do you want about
There. This should be better.
That's clean, right? You have a buffer
for
environment stuff.
Possibly we can even merge more than
this.
The policies like ArcMax fell.
No, it isn't.
What is it then? It's a sample.
It's a sample from a probability
distribution.
should be
theoretic.
The thing that you said doesn't make any
bloody sense.
expected
expectation
of
That's not even true if you have an
adversary in the game.
It's only true in
Is that even true?
It's still not freaking true in
deterministic games.
It's maybe it's true in deterministic
single agent fully observable games.
Maybe
like the thing here is you've entered
you've like entered a regime that
demands a lot of precision.
So you know if you're going to try to
like if you're going to try to do
something in this space it demands
precision.
You know, there's basically way you can
hand wave things and still have stuff
work. And this is not one of them.
It's not correct.
Your policy in rock paper scissors
should not be deterministic.
Rock paper scissors is deterministic.
Your adversary is not.
See, I mean like you see how it takes me
like literally 5 seconds to think about
these things as well.
Like this is what I mean by like if
you're going to be if you're going to be
thinking about things in this space, you
need to be very precise about things.
Now I have great news for you. um which
is if you want a space where things are
more empirical and don't need as precise
definitions
um if you just take general games or
general environments
basically no theory holds because the
vast majority of game theory as applied
to RL um POM DP theor whatever it just
breaks or gives you really crappy bounds
in sufficiently complex environments.
And then the things that end up work
working are quite simple and determined
empirically.
Those players are deterministic. No, it
doesn't. Right? Because determinism is
almost always referred to as a property
of the environment. And by the way, I
also you can get gotten um
you can get got basically even in
deterministic opponent deterministic
environment if it is partially
observable. Um so I can give you a
deterministic opponent that's just using
uh a r a seeded random value for the
moves but you can't observe the seed
then your optimal policy is still
stochastic.
So there are tons of gotchas.
You see how that works?
If from your perspective you can't
observe the seed so it looks like the
opponent is playing randomly then your
optimal policy is also to play randomly.
like a lot a lot of the holdup in the
field, right? A lot of the holdup in RL
is um people being too precise where the
precision doesn't matter and kind of
getting lost in the weeds and then
people not being precise enough where
the precision really does matter.
It's important to know which is which.
For instance, I would say exploration
research is an area where it's been held
back by people not being precise enough
with their definitions about what
they're even trying to solve and
thinking about the problems. And then um
like algorithm development has been held
up by being too precise about
definitions of various forms of MDPs and
POM DPS that don't actually map well to
the problems that people care about
solving
or that have very bad bounds.
which is some equilibrium. Last three
words, what does that mean?
If you care about other Nash equilibria
is my point.
So that's something about strategic
diversity in a game.
The simplest, most effective method for
this thus far has simply been um
fictitious selfplay or historical
selfplay.
Possibly some stuff with the exploiter
agents in the Alpha Star League. I think
it's probably overkill.
And also most real games don't look like
Nash equilibria either.
Policy function learning inefficiently.
No, I don't think that's the case.
That would be something you'd have to
demonstrate. And I don't think you can
demonstrate it because I don't know if
it's true.
There'd have to be a precise experiment.
Like you'd have to have a a specific
experiment set up.
NaS as it is now is also just never
going to work.
242.
I think we can try to get the Well, we
can have it update the test.
Means their mod API is pretty good.
[snorts]
Oh, they actually put the dragon in.
That's funny.
roll out end speed args.
Let's just wait on everything else.
Forward args
profile kernel run forward
arc policy.
This should now be substantially
simpler, right?
Let me see about this.
Quake three. Deep mind. Link the paper.
I swear if you link me the capture the
flag
Capture the flag. No, capture the flag
is demon.
That's the well-known one that's based
on Quake.
Open AI's hideandsek which is also a
merger tool use same project.
Okay. So it just duplicated all the
code.
they modded Quake. They just changed
some of the graphics. It's the same
Quake gameplay. I know.
The reason I said I swear if you link me
in that paper is because they didn't use
evolutionary strategies in the way that
you described. No, it's not a bad paper,
but I don't believe you. I don't believe
that you read it
because that's not what they use ES for.
They use it on a tiny little network
optimizing rewards. They basically use
it as a glorified hyperparameter search
over reward coefficients.
Not for the whole net.
I didn't. Well, if you didn't read the
paper, then why are you citing it at me,
right?
Unless you had a different paper in
mind.
I mean, you said something about like,
oh, you know, what about like ES being
more general because of this paper
suggesting it,
but you're suggesting to me a paper
that's interesting that I've read and
you haven't.
for a reason that you don't understand
because you haven't read the paper.
Like you say,
like if you read the paper and have some
like comment about, you know, the thing,
oh, could we do this with it? Know
that's one thing. But if you kind of
like point to a paper like vaguely, ah
yeah, they use the yes, they said it
would work there, but it's in like a
capacity that doesn't make any sense for
the thing that you're suggesting. That's
another thing, right?
Like if you're interested in this stuff,
it's worth the time. It's worth
investing the time to like at least get
the background to be able to speak and
think clearly
about at least a handful of the major
works in the space. Right? That's one of
maybe 10 papers that's actually worth
reading.
I believe I have that directly in my
guide as well. Hello, welcome.
Why is it not ES? God. Look, dude.
Look, I haven't read this paper in I
don't even know how many years. And
like, we'll see how quick this is.
Internal Reward.
All right. Right here. This is the thing
they use the S for on it, right? If I
recall,
they use game points PT winning signal.
This goes here. This goes to internal
reward. That goes to policy.
Um, where is the stupid thing?
Heck is it?
Game point signals.
Where are the features to this thing? I
think they're in the appendex.
If you go look at what they actually
did,
come on.
I publish papers in math. Then you
should be able to read it pretty easily.
Right? I mean, if you're interested in
this space, then you should just be able
to read some papers. Okay? Look, you see
this?
So, this is the vector that they give to
the agent. All right? They just made
like a bunch of booleans here and then
they use I think it's one layer, right?
It's either one layer or a very small
network and they used ES on the weights
of this thing. So basically all that
this thing does is learning some very
simple function of these.
So they're using this as a glorified
hyperparameter search not for actually
training the agent. Right?
So this is completely different from
learning like the actual weights of a
policy
with ES.
This is just them like wanting to do
some genetic thing and deciding to chuck
it on their um reward optimization.
And this is featurizing by the way. So
these are manually chosen features. So
they could have just as easily like
manually chosen some reward components
directly, right? And then they decide to
do ES over this thing
which is ludicrously inefficient because
they have unlimited deep mind compute.
like they would be way way way better
off if you didn't have this crazy amount
of compute to learn this function,
right? You just like take all these
components and you would just like
actually I think it's literally the same
thing cuz Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It is. It's
actually the same thing as what I'm
saying. Isn't that nuts? So, I think it
is literally just they learn one weight
for each of these things. You would just
do this with a hyperparameter search.
You don't need ES at all.
So, I know this because DeepMind loves
to do [ __ ] like this. They like to use
the super sexy technique that sounds
super fun in general when it just like
whatever doesn't like you can do it if
you have unlimited compute, but it
doesn't make it smart.
Yes, neural MMO initializes the same net
along among all the agents and it does
here as well except for this tiny little
thing plus their leagues which is
independent.
This network is just them doing
different reward shaping
does not depend on ES. They use ES
instead of just doing hyperp search.
And actually, just to show you, if I
check my article here,
watch this.
I only recommend one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10. I
recommend here 11 papers here in my read
these papers section. And this is one of
them.
Yes, but the thing is you're conflating
two things, right? You're conflating
their tournament setup with their use of
ES.
These two things are completely
independent.
The tournament setup is like sort of
similar to the Alpha Star League thing.
Doesn't depend on evolution at all and
is um to be determined competitive
alternative or not uh with historical
selfplay. It's certainly more compute
expensive. We don't know if it's better.
Add these to my reading list. Yeah, it's
all in that article, man. If you just
follow through that article, that
article will take you through the
process of learning RL.
Multi-agent stuff with tournaments.
Yeah. So, multi-agent stuff with
tournaments. Um, the problem is it's
slow.
So, you can do it and it's reasonable,
but it's slow. Historical selfplay is
dramatically faster and often good
enough. It was good enough for Dota.
So, you can do full league stuff. It's
guaranteed slow though because you're
splitting your compute among uh many
different policies evenly. Whereas with
historical selfplay, you take maybe a
20% perfect at most
I believe that the other paper I
suggested is literally the first one.
It's the open AI5 paper.
In my view, that's the best paper in the
field.
deterministic. Then if it's determinized
early, your hypers are bad.
Um,
we need puffer four. Yes, we do need
puffer four. I do need to focus on this
a bit. So,
All right. I was on this thing.
Okay. So,
I'm going to let it do this for now.
This is basically us not being able to
include the file, which is why this is
putting all this crap here. So, this is
now duplicating [ __ ] in two places uh
into the tests.
I mean it's a reasonably interesting
discussion E10 but it's like a rather
uninformed discussion like it would be
much better if you read the if you read
the paper right and then decided whether
there was stuff that was interesting to
discuss
like the only reason I'm being rude to
you now is because you're trying to
discuss something that you haven't read.
Otherwise, I'd be more than happy to be
discussing it much more politely.
Yeah. So, this is literally just copying
code over.
What are we working on? I'm a newbie.
Then follow my guide, man. My guide
would have had you reading this, right?
My guide is like pretty short. It
doesn't give you like three years worth
of reading.
I promise you that if you go through the
list there and you like do some of the
stuff that's there like you'll you'll
have be able to have way way way better
discussions. You'll be shocked how
quickly you can learn the stuff
especially if you have math background
for it.
Okay. So, I'm going to just let this
copy this thing over because this is
literally just um it's basically
duplicating all the new code changes
into profile because we don't have um a
reasonable way to include the code
without just copying it yet because we
got to refactor stuff. But I want to at
least have this runnable and then we'll
see what we do from here. [snorts]
Uh what we're working on today is
refactoring the uh puffer lib C++ code
for puffer 4 because we hit the speed
target but it's a total mess and we have
some reasonable profiling now.
Uh the profiling is super verbose. It
needs to be way shorter. I refactored a
bunch of stuff that should make it
easier to profile. And uh first we're
going to do the ver verbose version with
the new style. And then I'm gonna
actually have to go figure out how we
move some stuff around so I can actually
uh include the code from another file
instead of just like duplicating stuff.
It's actually kind of annoying in C++ to
be splitting things up to different
files because I don't want to generate a
a whole bunch of redundant headers.
Read the puffer algorithm. The puffer
algorithm is very simple, right? It's
like a very simple set of changes on PO.
It's not meant to be like super
intellectually impressive or anything,
but it does work and it works very well.
I'd say as far as like if you want
something that's a little bit more
impressive algorithmically, I'd say
protein is something I'm quite a bit
more proud of.
Like our hyperparameter tuning is pretty
cool.
But yeah, for anybody watching, if you
want to be able to like discuss this
stuff with me live, it it's really it
depends on what background you're coming
in with. But if you're able to like
start on this stuff and you don't have a
whole bunch of background to do before
you even start, the actual content of
this article is not that that long,
right? Like there's some stuff for
Puffer building a couple basic hyperfs.
This just requires like very simple
systems dev background. One undergrad
course is plenty. Um
it takes you through like building a
slightly bigger project that you could
actually PR. It gives you all my
references like the references to all my
favorite papers that I think are
actually worth reading. It gives you
some really good general advice on how
to think about things.
Links a few cool applications.
Links a few algorithms I'm thinking
about. I actually think um
I actually think that this is a bit
dated now where like these I think these
were questions I'm thinking about,
right? And this one I think I've more or
less resolved. And I don't think off
policy is actually that worth it. And I
don't think that um modelbased is that
worth it. At least not in the way that's
presented here. Search still
questionable. Info way more important at
the moment.
There you go. I should do an update to
that guide.
It's pretty much all up to date except
that one like that one section on
essentially my current thoughts on
interesting open problems and research.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, cool. So, this actually
this is that it runs
We should actually have the name space
in here.
Less than 1% of people will do the
complete thing. Well, I mean doing the
complete thing is like if you want to
actually get into research and be, you
know, productive in the field, then I
provided a way to do so that is like
dramatically dramatically faster than
the uh the normal recommendations
can only do so much, right? I can't like
dump all RL knowledge to you in five
minutes, right?
I also I made it incremental where like
a you can do a good chunk of stuff in
there in a weekend if you have even
basic systems dev like you will learn so
much just making a couple environments
you know reading a couple of the papers
in detail you learn a lot very quickly
Okay.
I'll let it I'll let it just do this
because this is all going to get removed
in a second.
But I don't want to have to think about
this until we do the next chunk of it.
Yeah, this is just C++ junk. Let me
start thinking though about how I'm
going to actually split this up. So,
this is reasonable.
I think I just need to include the damn
C++ file.
Learn what not what not to do
with they're not interlin with puffer,
dude.
Did you check the Did you check the
list? Like look, Dota Open AI. Cool.
Uh,
Starcraft 2, Alpha Star, Deep Mind, Deep
Mind, Open AI,
uh, Deep Mind, Open AI,
Deep Mind,
Meta SL, uh, whatever,
uh, Open AI, but really more Schulman
personally. Schulman, and then original
deep mind. They're all Open AI and deep
mind papers because that was the golden
era. I didn't work at both of those
places. I was at OpenAI for like six
months.
>> Yeah. But other than this one really
kind of cool environment like the vast
majority of the papers uh the good
papers that actually work are from
OpenAI and Deep Mind.
techniques you have or want to
implement.
There are a bunch of different papers
though. There's some core algorithm work
in there.
Um, there are like a number of different
like largecale problems that just show
what it actually took to get RL working
on a very hard problem.
There's some cool environments in there,
right? Some cool concepts on building
useful environments.
I definitely don't want to implement
most of the stuff in there either,
especially the um the deep mind ones
have like a lot of just fancy stuff.
Okay, this is like brain damage. So,
what I need to do is let's get this
thing running and then we'll have it
remove all this duplicate code and then
I'll actually be left with an amount
that I can check manually
name space. Okay. So,
let's actually just do it this way.
We'll just have it include the file.
Literally did it wrong.
Oops.
Wait, what?
No. Okay, that thing I
I freaking hate this thing. You know
what? Let's just do this.
That's what I was going to do next.
Anyways,
be possible to replicate Starcraft Dota.
Yeah. So, that's the thing. Country,
you'd have to write you'd have to write
the end. If you wanted to do it um at
our normal speeds without spending a ton
of money, you'd need to have a fast
version of the end.
I mean, presumably we could at least get
it faster than they have it,
but I don't know how like I don't know
what the cost would be because you need
a ton of samples.
we'll let it do this because I'm going
to move it after anyways.
Like you see what stupid stuff though it
recommends. Like it just decides to
guard this
with this so that it doesn't like it can
include the file
instead of deciding hey maybe this
should go in the binding in a bindings
file.
Okay, you see this giant delete? This is
actually correct. This is because all of
this crap was being duplicated before.
Copy pasted because of the janky
includes
Should be much more of this that can be
deleted.
It's probably not going to realize it
though.
It's very funny cuz like this thing
doesn't feel smart. This thing feels
like um careful,
relatively careful, not smart.
and that it can apply um precisely
described transformations to code and it
can do so in a way that it it will be
more careful than I am just like sitting
here being kind of tired.
Um
but I definitely don't trust it to do
anything other than that.
But hey, precisely described
transformations, that's already very
useful as a tool.
How many sample
games do you need for what
sample games?
I mean Dota they trained on a like huge
amount
of data they trained on I don't know it
was like I think they said they trained
on it was like a hundred some odd years
per day but then they ran it for months.
So I mean we actually can get that scale
on one machine uh with our M but not
with like slow M's, right?
Okay, this I'm happy with. We can do
this
Why the hell would you ask it to do get
commands in the first place?
Replicate the mechanics up until Yeah,
exactly. It's just we write a fast
version of whatever the target is,
Liberty. Because like the thing is most
stuff that is slow is slow for no real
good reason.
It turns out we can just make stuff
fast. Nice.
That sounds awful. Ethan,
I'd way rather do the opposite.
Writing unit tests all day sounds no
fun.
though I will
uh it makes sense for a couple very
niche things like um for instance if you
have numeric checks on kernels
but then you still don't want to just
let the thing write a kernel it'll screw
up
so I think still I probably use the the
model more in writing the the um the
test than I did in writing the kernel
like in the sense that I had to do way
more manually of it.
You can't let the AI write the colonels.
They [ __ ] it up.
Okay, it doesn't work. It's completely
wrong and irreparably like stupid. What
do you do? Well, you have to write it
yourself.
And what ends up happening?
What the hell?
Oh, that's fine.
Yep, that's actually good. Yeah, you're
allowed to do that.
Need to read a bunch of code. Well, then
you read a bunch of code.
It's not reading that much faster
actually at the moment. It's kind of
slow.
do that. I think that'll still conflict,
but we will see.
Then I have no idea what it's doing for
the rest of the time because if it could
go through that many input tokens, it
should be much faster.
I think it actually takes it several
minutes to read that amount of code.
I don't know what the actual token per
second is on this thing.
If we're calling agent thing that reads
code in loops
Fine.
I think that's it for VC.
I can tell you've outsourced way too
much of your thinking.
Like there's a reason I do things this
way.
And this is the most I use the model by
the way.
Not remotely this much if I'm like
building a new env or something. This is
because I'm refactoring a highly
redundant boilerplate heavy crap,
right?
Yeah, something got messed up in the
setup. Most likely
Maybe I can do two things at the same
time and then do them both badly.
I'm focused at the moment on how this
thing should be restructured
so it doesn't make a mess and need a
bunch of dumb headers.
Yes, this is what needed to move. That's
fine.
Oh, shoot. The dictionary.
Okay. It'll need a wrapper. Yeah, it'll
need a small rapper.
Are you waiting or thinking? That's the
trick is that you have to still be
thinking about it
or you lose context on the problem.
be good to not have this in um in here.
Anyways,
if the agent was at one token per
second, I wouldn't use it, dude.
Yes, this is correct.
This does go in the binding.
Little sketchy on the um the gill stuff
here.
I think we're going to hit a problem
with the uh the gill release.
Build this thing.
I build torch.
So, I don't know if this is going to be
too much is the problem.
What happened?
I saw that some people got hired back. I
didn't see much else.
Okay.
Now, I suspect what's going to happen
here is that the scoping has to be more
precise.
Okay, that actually does work. Very
nice.
Do we train stable?
We do train stable.
Solid.
Like I would have gone and joined one if
I wanted to.
Okay. Something screw happened with
Muan.
That's way better.
There's still much more to be done, but
I mean, right now, Puffer is the
it's the small model RL
lab, right?
Like nobody else has anything remotely
like this in our area
uh since like the second stream. I don't
use it for everything though. Like this
is a particularly good application
because it's just a bunch of bullshitty
template matching.
What happened here?
Presumably there's a bunch of other
stuff.
Now, this is still 1,700 freaking lines.
Um, but it's 1,700 lines that we're
duping everything,
right?
At
least I'm pretty sure
look.
Not this one.
I think it's the stuff down here gets
duped.
The kernel profiles are fine. It's the
um
it's the highle prop that's redundant.
probably a few hundred lines worth.
Okay. I forgot we added this kernel as
well.
Yeah. So, all the freaking forward
functions
That's what I thought. Why you think
there aren't more people?
Because the hype thing is LLMs.
I'm missing something. Of course,
they're just focused on their thing.
You think they care? They're getting
investments. They're getting money.
They've got some tech.
They're not thinking about getting every
possible thing done in science.
She develop
what that is killing it clots.
Why aren't they dedicating it small
team? Cuz they went all in on the one
pretty shiny thing.
It's really not that complicated.
It's like when I was young, I also
thought that every important problem out
there had a team of brilliant scientists
working on it. That's just not how the
world works.
The profiler shouldn't have the fre
shouldn't have freaking Adam
And then this profile kernels file
should get down to I don't know 1,200
lines maybe.
I think the hyper setup can get reused
as well.
1,600. This should be shorter.
Uh, it should have gotten way shorter
than this. So, we'll see what happened.
This runs now. Why did this not get way
shorter?
Quick commit here.
Get some drinks.
should now be getting shorter.
Should be getting shorter, not longer
Now we'll start getting um something
rather quick here I'd imagine from
That's
This one function that I have to have is
very stupid.
That's torch being dumb though. I can't
do anything about that.
Yeah, I'd like this file to end up being
all these graph ops mostly.
We can move.
What else is in here that doesn't need
to be here?
Yes, this doesn't need to be here
either.
annoying that it's also messing with
this file, so I can't just edit it now.
Okay,
all this stuff is fine.
So, where's the [ __ ] that I don't
want to be here?
Okay, actually, a lot of it is the
models.
Yeah, 578 lines worth of models.
I don't know why the [ __ ] it put cosine
and there. It's just dumb.
I'll let it do that. I'll move cosine
kneeling back in.
What's this min grew? Okay, so it is
actually
most of the redundant crap is in fact
the models that should just be in their
own spot. And then we have a bunch of
these forward decks that need to get
moved into um colonel land.
There's also this environment stuff that
we need to figure out still. And then
the only other thing I see is this clip
bradnorm which is I can't do much about
that. This exists because torch is
stupid.
So
100 lines of torch being stupid. The
rest of it pretty reasonable.
Way better than before. Let me say
I'm surprised I haven't gone through all
my tokens as well.
I don't know. Not bad for um one day
refactor.
It was very funny when they said, "Oh,
no. We're not testing." The one What's
bad about this is that they said, "Oh
yeah, we're not testing abs." And then
like literally one month later they do
this.
Okay, so this gets moved. This is
literally just moving code. That's fine.
We're not going to have too many files.
I think it's just going to be the
policy.
Okay. Like this this stuff, dude. Why
the [ __ ] is this down here, right?
Yeah, you can just you can go here
or whatever.
And then uh this one can go.
Uh this one actually can go back I
suppose
because of the way we have it for now.
Clip rador can stay where it is.
I'm getting hungry as well. I think um
my family kind of planned an early
dinner. I might just do that.
rather than like sit here all day. Long
stream been six hours. We've made some
good progress.
I mean, the rest of this should be very
easy for me to just have Claude move
around.
really just do not like the way that
modules work. C++ one bit
weird name space crap.
should be researched and isn't besides
RL probably tons of stuff but the thing
is
I don't have a deep knowledge of every
branch of science. I can say that based
on what I'm doing in RL I think that a
lot of areas of science that heavily
leverage simulation are going to see a
lot of benefit from this stuff. I don't
know like what other areas are just
being completely neglected in the exact
same way though, right? Like how would I
What do you want to get done for puffer
4?
Oops. Did I build this correctly? Um,
well, this whole thing needs to be
cleaned up. It needs to work with all of
our ends. I need to be happy with the
state of the code. I need to be happy
that we have uh good profiling on every
possible chunk of the code pretty much.
I need to run quite a few tests on the
new architecture to make sure it's as
good as I think it is. Um
and then pretty much once I have the
whole of the new low uh the new backend
integrated then I need to do
constellation which is the experimental
chunk of it. We have tons of experiments
to launch
and there will be quite a bit of writing
and polish as well involved with the
release.
There we go. That's nice.
Yeah, this works.
Here's the restroom real quick and go
grab one more drink and then we will
finish this junk off. Okay.
Okay, let's finish this last chunk of
work.
The one thing that I don't have, we
don't have CPU fallbacks for um for
literally anything at one second.
Okay. Yeah, we don't have CPU fallbacks
uh for literally anything other than
this kernel.
I never found a good way to do that,
unfortunately.
Make sure the profiler works and the
main build works.
And then this is like
I'm going to say that the progress from
today is we almost have it in a form
that like looks similar to something
shippable.
That's about the level we're at now.
Before it was just like colossal mess.
Now it's mostly like high level kind of
okay. A few major things to fix, a lot
of minor things to fix, but looks
reasonable.
I don't really Do I care about CPU
fallbacks? I might still care about CPU
fallbacks.
Sound beat. Yeah,
I'm going to have like a really early
dinner and call tonight.
I don't think I'm quite sick, but I
think I'm um I was probably exposed to
something and fighting it
Cosign and nailing for reward decided.
total time steps in chess.
End of duplicating that.
Yeah. So that's the annoying thing,
right? Is that you don't know the total
time steps
and like presumably it's now you have to
go across the subprocess barrier as well
which is annoying.
Yeah, I don't have a great way other
than like special case just adding a
function for your thing, right?
This is one of the annoying things about
uh multiple languages plus subprocesses
plus all this crap is very difficult to
communicate stuff. Like I'm sure you can
hack it, but I don't have a clean way to
do it.
Okay, we still run.
Still trying.
Yes, that's solid.
Okay.
How's my file? Everything's way more
reasonable.
Major Batman vibes. I'm feel great
today. I'm uh cozy Saturday. I figured
I'd still stream though.
action route. Yeah, try that, Jess. See
if it works. It's going to be annoying
because like it'll change the buffer
shapes and stuff.
Socket. No, that's going to be super
slow.
I mean, this is like
I'm going to say decent overall at
least.
We didn't get multiple ends in today.
Um,
that was maybe a bit too ambitious.
Can we get rid of these awful decks?
like
decided to do it with echo.
So weird.
[snorts]
Funny echo pattern.
So, I still don't know how I want to do
um all the includes for this crap. We're
not having for everything. That sounds
like awful.
I'm getting tired for today, so I'm
going to end up having to stop anyways.
But, um,
yeah, I think there's still some moving
around of stuff needed.
There aren't actually any CUDA functions
here, right?
I think we still need to get into like
the mod the whole modules business is
like weird.
forge modules. We also have the Bflat 16
stuff to try. Um,
you know, we're nowhere near done
unfortunately, but we've made good
progress.
Okay, so it's not getting double
appended fine
That's better. Tried to probably hash
include the kernels code. Pound include
zoomer hash include
launch functions needs to go
four declarations for the launch
functions. Really?
Oh, god damn it.
Fine, we'll figure this thing out later.
That's what I didn't want, man.
Fine, we'll do this [ __ ] for now.
We're not keeping that.
I really really just hate headers as a
concept.
I hate the idea of having to duplicate
[ __ ] in extra time for the sake of it.
And then you get programmers where it's
literally like a compiler quirk. Um, and
they'll say, "Oh, no, actually you need
header files. How on how else will you
know what the function signatures are?
I'm not happy with that." But Oh, come
on.
See, like this is where it starts doing
awful [ __ ]
again. This file is not going to
continue to exist.
Oh, this is using torch. No, this is
stupid.
I I'll let it do this but to see if it
works but I doubt it.
Oh no. It does it put it in colonel CU.
No. Undo that.
Look how stupid this thing is.
You're going to tell me these models are
smart.
[ __ ] hell. Oh yo.
I mean, this is why I had
this is why I had it included in the
first place, right? So they didn't have
to deal with this [ __ ]
I'm going to figure this out later. I'm
going to leave this uncommitted for now
because I got to get to dinner.
But there's a great demonstration of why
you don't just let Opus do things.
I'm gonna have to figure it out. I'm
going to have to myself think about how
I want to structure this so we don't
have like horrible include hell.
Um, thank you all for tuning in. I'll be
back most likely on Monday. If you're
interested in my stuff generally, please
feed the puffer star at puffer.ai.
Like, feed this guy a star. He likes
stars. Almost to 5K. And follow me on X
for more RL content. And you can join
Discord to get involved with dev.
Goodbye. Paty weekend.